-President Trump has been
holding
a lot of press briefings
lately,
but his rambling, nonsensical
responses
leave a lot of important
questions unanswered.
So we decided to hold another
one right here, right now.
Unfortunately, the rest of
the "Late Night" press corps
couldn't make it tonight because
they're still waiting on their
COVID test results.
But President Trump is here,
and he's ready to go.
So without further ado,
it's time
for the "Late Night" White House
press briefing.
♪♪
-Mr. President, Mr. President,
Mr. President, Mr. President.
Thank you, Seth Meyers,
"Late Night With Seth Meyers."
President Trump, what would you
say to reassure people
with pre-existing conditions
who are terrified
of catching the coronavirus?
-The stock market went up
358 points today.
-And what would you say
to reassure the people
who have been fortunate enough
to avoid catching the virus
thus far?
-You'll have it very shortly.
-How would you describe
the 2020 presidential race?
-Elderly.
It's especially elderly.
-And what are you hoping
to see on November 3rd?
-A rigged election.
-In your opinion, what is
the most egregious offense
the media can commit?
-Not talking about me.
-And what can you tell me about
that suit you're wearing?
-Covers a lot of territory.
-Hey, tell us, when you
meet another world leader,
how do you shake their hand?
-Very, very strongly and, uh,
very, very hard.
-How many states do you
think you'll carry
in the election?
-40, 50, 60, and maybe even 70.
-Well, 70, that's something.
You don't seem to have as many
friends as you used to.
Why is that?
-They're being arrested,
they're being put in jail.
And that's why you see
those numbers going down.
-How would you describe
Switzerland's flag?
-It's a big plus.
-If Chris Cuomo competed
at the Olympics,
what kind of medal
do you think he'd win?
-Fake media gold.
-What are your pants like
as you lie your way through
these press briefings?
-Pretty much on fire.
-President Trump,
a geography question.
How frackin' big is Texas?
-That's a big fracking state.
-[ Laughs ]
What's your youngest
daughter's name?
-Jennifer.
-No, actually, it's Tiffany.
The answer you were looking for
was Tiffany.
Okay.
How'd you do on your S.A.T.s?
-Half a million incorrect.
-What do you call a sandwich
on a hamburger bun
made with ground beef, onions,
tomato sauce, and Ambien?
-Sleepy Joe.
-When your son Eric
was conceived,
which of your sperm
fertilized the egg?
-The slowest, weakest,
and worst.
-What was Charles Barkley's
most impressive skill
on the basketball court?
-Rebounding with strength like
nobody thought possible.
-The round mound to rebound.
Is there anything you'd like to
say to all the chairs
you've sat on over the years?
-I want to thank them
for their strength,
their bravery.
-What's your favorite part
of a Michael Bay movie?
-An automobile boom.
-Like an explosion?
What do you need in order
to fix your brain?
-The largest and most advanced
operation of its kind
anywhere in the world
and anywhere in history.
-Is it true that you're
writing a Broadway musical?
-A lot of people are
going to be very happy
when they see some
of the numbers.
-Yeah, I mean,
I can't wait for that.
Here's a question
about romance.
What did Melania say the first
time she saw you naked?
-Gee, I don't know exactly
what that is.
-Oh.
Hey, I'm looking
to score a little --
[ Inhales ]
You know anyone I should
talk to about that?
-Chuck Schumer
and Nancy Pelosi are holding.
-Wow! Chuck and Nancy.
Who would have thought?
Hey, why did we never get to see
Wilson on "Home Improvement"?
-The fencing -- especially
the new fencing
that they put up is
very powerful.
-Uh-huh. Com--
Complete this famous
song lyric --
♪ A, B, C, D, E, F, G... ♪
-HHS and CDC.
[ Laughter ]
Ah!
What's your favorite
John Carpenter movie?
-The fog was so great.
-Yeah, it is, but what is,
uh, that one,
you know, it takes
place in Antarctica?
You know, Kurt Russell?
-That's the thing.
-"The Thing"!
That's right.
What would happen
if I opened up, like,
a hundred tabs in Safari?
-You will have a crash like
you've never seen before.
-What country is your wife
Melania from?
-The Netherlands.
-Nope.
-Sweden.
-Belgium.
-Nope.
-Estonia?
-Slovakia?
-Neh, I'll give it to you.
What's the highest number
you can count to?
-A number that nobody's ever
heard of before.
-Why did you stop wearing
an adult diaper?
-Don't like to put it on
because it shows.
-Looks like we have time
for one more question.
What did Melania say to you
on your birthday?
-We could do it through
teleconference.
-Well, it looks like
we're out of time.
So on behalf of the rest of
the "Late Night" press corps,
have a good night.